[Musique]
mon métier c'était
14 heures
chaque jour
100 km environ
je travaillais du lundi au samedi
y compris les jours fériés
je travaillais aussi de nuit pour ne pas
déranger mes clients
je m'appelle patricia je suis agent
d'entretien
pendant plusieurs années mon quotidien
c'était 3 heures du matin le réveil
sonne
une douche un café vite avalé
une vérification des affaires des
enfants que je m'en voudrais pas à
l'école et hop c'est parti
4h30 direction un siège social 6 heures
le nettoyage d'un grand magasin avant
l'ouverture pour les clients
et puis le jour se lève en est là eh ben
je vais là où elle demande un magasin un
stade
le midi je retourne au siège social pour
faire une repasse ne repasse c'est quoi
eh bien c'est la vérification des
toilettes du savon des essuie-mains
vider les poubelles les réfectoires
et l'après midi eh bien je poireaute
parce que je dois retourner au magasin
de bricolage il est bas avant 16h30
juste pour 1h
19 heures
je termine après 45 minutes dans une
agence bancaire
sacré quotidien que celui de nos agents
d'entretien je m'appelle philippe je
suis dirigeant d'entreprise quand il ya
quelques années avec mon équipe je
découvre le quotidien des salariés qui
entretiennent nos bureaux c'est un
véritable choc
ce choc c'est un choc de confort d'abord
faut avoir conscience du confort que
nous avons parce que quand on arrive et
bien tout est entretenu tout est parfait
tout est nickel alors pourquoi changer
oui bien sûr il ya des salariés qui font
ça mais quelque part ils sont payés pour
ça et puis ça justifie leur job
et bien là on se décide d'y fait pas
possible on va travailler pour que ça
change on travaille avec patricia et
avec la tri science met d'accord sur des
horaires de jour à la place de la nuit
et là ça va tout changer ça va tout
changer évidemment pour patricia mais ça
va changer aussi pour nous parce qu'on
s'aperçoit qu'on va gagner en dialogue
entre nous en fait patricia bas nous
dire par exemple c'est bizarre ces deux
bureaux là j'ai l'impression qu'à pas
grand monde
eh ben on va lui dire mais bien raison
patricia ses bureaux lassé des bureaux
de commerciaux ils ne viennent qu'une ou
deux fois par semaine à quoi ça sert d
entretenir tous les jours on va passer à
1 en mode à un entretien une fois par
semaine ou deux fois par semaine
à l'opposé telles salles de réunion
elle est en permanence remplie il ya des
pots il ya des événements il ya des
réunions et donc là il faut passer deux
fois par semaine et donc on va s'adapter
petit à petit on va mettre ensemble en
place des règles qui vont permettre de
bien fonctionner
toutes ces règles c'est grâce à la
visibilité de patricia qu'elle se met en
place parce que les salariés peuvent
discuter au quotidien ce côté visible en
fait il est extrêmement fort et je
voudrais vous interrogez qui parmi vous
connaît le prénom de la personne qui
entretient beaux locaux vos immeubles
votre bureau votre association votre
collectivité
en général
assez peu de personnes et pourquoi on
les connaît pas tout simplement parce
qu'ils travaillent essentiellement le
week end
et puis la nuit
la nuit
ben la nuit tout est noir
la nuit qui dit nuit
dit silence
qui dit silence dit
eh bien j'ai peur je me sens pas en
sécurité
le bruit
quand il est là
ça vous fait sursauter ya pas de vous et
la nuit
il y a même parfois
vous vous imaginez des ombres
et surtout vos gestes ils deviennent
mécanique en mode robot
vous faites votre taf
et pour la poussière à poussière la nuit
et ben ne se voit pas
petite question
il y en a combien parmi vous qui ont
fait des vitres à 5 heures du matin
et va revenir aux vous verrez le
résultat
et le jour alors du coup patriciens le
jour
par en parler du jour est bien le jour
eh ben c'est jour et la nuit
puis les monologues
fini ces questions sans réponse
j'ai mes clients je les vois je les
entends et j'ai aussi cette bonne odeur
de café
et puis vous avez aussi et c'est
existentielle ce bonjour bonjour
ça c'est le monsieur qui a la photo de
ses enfants dans la piscine
et là c'est cette petite dame avec ses
stylos payet et son plein sur son
fauteuil
et ben vous vous avez envie de les
chouchouter vous avez envie de les
soigner de prendre soin d'eux parce qu
ils vont tous remarqué la
nuit le bruit c'est quoi c'est
l'inquiétude c'est l'angoissé c'est
oppressant le jour eh ben le bruit c'est
la vie
et finalement ce qu'on va découvrir
c'est leur aspect le besoin de respect
et le fait que les gens vont devenir
responsable de l'entretien on voit
patricia et du coup on devient
responsable de l'état général du
nettoyage
je veux raconter une petite anecdote
j'aime beaucoup les bradl au sésame vous
savez ces friandises là qui sont très
friable et qui laisse plein de miettes
et parfois le soir quand je quittais mon
bureau se regardait par terre
c'était pas parfait
on a une petite culpabilité mais cette
culpabilité elle passe pourquoi parce
que y'a une fée qui existent et qui va
passer et lendemain matin finalement
tout est oublié donc bon ben vous pouvez
continuer à manger les bretelles au
sésame
quand on connaît patricia quand on sait
que ça patriciens qui entretient votre
culpabilité elle passe moins vite
en fait quand on connaît la personne qui
entretient les locaux les endroits où
vous passez et ben je dirais vous êtes
beaucoup plus responsable et c'est ça
qu'on a gagné c'est qu'on s'est aperçu
que l'ensemble du personnel était
devenue beaucoup plus responsables y
compris aux toilettes patriciens
et
bien je tiens à dire que ces messieurs
ils avancent d'un pas devant les
urinoirs
mais il ya aussi ces dames elles savent
tout jouer au basket maintenant les
essuie mains
et moi j'ai ce sourire de patricia
se sont ré patricia parce qu'on sait
qu'on a amélioré sa vie mais on sait
aussi que ça à améliorer la qualité de
ce qu'on a fait il ya bien plus que ça
il ya le lien que créer patricia parce
qu'en fait patricia vous en connaissez
beaucoup des salariés qui font tous les
bureaux chaque jour qui disent bonjour à
quasiment tous les employés tous les
jours
l'agent d'entretien en fait c'est un
véritable révélateur de lien social qui
peut exister dans une entreprise il fait
du relationnel et ça c'est un point
vraiment majeur
et puis il ya eu la qu'ovide patricia et
pendant la coved les salariés n'avaient
pas tellement envie de revenir au bureau
et en fait ce qu'il a à faire revenir au
bureau c'est la garantie de sécurité
qu'on leur a donné hélas patricia avait
de nouveau un rôle essentiel parce qu'il
y avait tous ces fameux points contacts
vous savez ces rampes d'escalier ses
poignées de portes et bien patricia elle
les faisait 2 3 fois par jour et là ça
finissait par rassurer l'ensemble des
salariés
alors
qu'est ce qui a changé pour moi d'être
passé deux jours
eh bien je suis fier je suis heureuse
ans je suis visible
gevo regard
je me sens femme à et j'existe
donc si vous avez ce pouvoir d'influer
sur le passage des agents d'entretien de
la nuit au jour fait le fait le pas ce
que vous allez évidemment améliorer leur
vie mais vous allez gagner sur la
qualité du nettoyage en rendant les
salariés responsables et en augmentant
le relationnel dans l'entreprise et même
si vous auriez pas ce pouvoir on est
tous à un moment donné utilisateurs d'
espaces publics ici on est en train
d'utiliser une salle il ya quelqu'un qui
va derrière nettoyer mois
il ya des ondes utilisées transports en
commun on est dans la rue il ya des
cantonniers qui vont nettoyer encore une
fois si on connaissait le nom des
personnes qui entretenait on serait
beaucoup plus responsable donc on a tous
cette responsabilité en nous moi je ne
quitte plus une chambre d'hôtel sans
faire un minimum de remise en place ces
trois fois rien on remet la couette en
place on ouvre la fenêtre hors menu de
trois coups ça c'est une ou deux minutes
mais pour la personne qui va prendre
soin de la chambre derrière ça change
tout
tous ensemble nous avons ce pouvoir de
dire au revoir au travail dans le noir
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]